this week public remarks by people
involved in political leadership but a
lot of us very upset
the charming Joe Marnie ex-girlfriend of
the UK party leader revealed not for the
first time that there are people in this
country who see black people as ugly and
the forthcoming Royal Wedding as a
process of tainting royal blood Donald
Trump managed to simultaneously offend
anyone with small children who now ask
what a certain word beginning with s and
ending in hole means people from African
nations a mere 15% of the entire world's
population and people with immigrant
backgrounds which is basically all
Americans why are we all so surprised
that these remarks I wasn't in fact I
was relieved both Trump and money were
just declaring loudly be ignorant so
many people including politicians
celebrities and the media have thought
quietly now that their comments are out
there it's so much harder for anyone to
be in denial about the existence of
these views and their influence and
perversely
that may in fact be a good thing I mean
I take a huge issue was what I just said
that declaring loudly the ignorance of
many many people I mean you're basically
saying there that there are whole swath
of this country who are racist which is
absolutely not true and and and and you
know the insinuation that that people
have treated Megan Markel in any other
way that's it's positive the media for
instance the insinuation is that the
media have treated her badly and you're
saying that the media record what roger
mark what you what she called germany
has said what she said was megan Markel
is ugly that her seed will taint the
royal family that we don't want other
races and cultures to invade ours that
she's the gender equality something
beginning with T and that she's a Dom
little act as no one's ever heard of I
have heard no one in this country in the
media or anyone else come close to
saying or thinking those vile comments
in fact I won't talk about the media in
the sense that I think they have
everything that they have
welcome to their being positive
everything she has she has talked about
her race more than anyone else and the
media have reported that faithfully in
the most in the most empowering way I
think and I think if anyone in this
country thinks about Megan Markel they
they think about the fact that that that
she they think about her ethnicity in a
very very positive way you said
something that you said recent you said
after this engagement now would not be
possible to argue that being black is
incompatible with being British and
that's the reaction I see from almost
everyone in this country the fact that
that that that someone from an ethnic
background is in the world from you all
said in another piece I've been reading
up about in this week around
now you said same piece actually you
said that you've got a feeling that the
monarchy was fundamental to Britishness
but the Britishness they represent an
excuse you know now it doesn't exclude
you and it's fantastic and to actually
say that this is the ignorance of lots
of the views these views represent the
views of lots of people in this country
I think it's really insulting to the
people of this country who have done
nothing but a door Megan Markel well
first of all thank you for reading and
fighting so many miles I've coined a new
word and so having read my articles
Carol you'll know that I massively
welcome the coming royal wedding and the
fact that you're simon else in this
close
not everyone else but carol will just
wave your first of all let me ask you a
question right where do you think joe
Marnie's views come from do you think
they come out of nowhere out of thin air
no I think what she said was vile but
what do mean where do I think they camp
again from her head that came from what
she believes and what she thinks but you
can't say the way I guess those are you
think that heavily Nelson this country
has now and I didn't say everyone
anything you say those words you said
loudly the ignorance by so many people
you said so many I said ignorance by so
many people surely it's young that's my
question well I don't know where it come
so how do I know where viewers come from
it didn't take did it take what mr.
Trump a president Trump said and what
Joe Marty said for you to realize that
unfortunately there is and I'd kind of
find for Carol a little bit please God
it's a decreasing
there is always going to be a bunch of
people in school sure didn't need to
have those remarks for the light to go
on over that did you well you say that
Nick but I'm so answered what both of
you are saying I think it's it's we
often congratulate ourselves in this
country for being tolerant a word which
I have an issue with by the way because
if you think about tolerance what it
actually means is that you look a bit
brown and you eat different food but I'm
gonna put up with you being in my
environment think about what tolerance
me there's almost like I'll do you a
favor by accept you why do you need to
be tolerant to accept that there are
people around you because there was a
time when people weren't tolerant and
then anger easy but that's not all right
Carol and you you don't give it you
don't give us credit you know another
thing you said about about a note in
that that same piece you said that the
royal family was the antithesis of
diversity it isn't now time has moved on
yeah people's views have changed
that's a Fanta I mean you're fighting
what I fed for I agree it's a
fantastically but you seem to be
struggling there's a huge huge sways of
this control bring everyone else in but
just just to finish responding to you I
think I what you're saying about the
media welcoming Megan mark overall
wedding yeah I think now it's more or
less true which is one almost as well
that's not actually is not true
Carol Prince Harry yeah issued a
statement unprecedented statement for
royal himself pointing to the racism in
the media coverage when his relationship
with Megan mark was first and out so if
you think I'm a fantasist then you have
to say to Harry that as well because if
he called out the racism had been
literally immediate anyway Michele was
getting into it
reading the same newspapers where did
that come from and therefore it's not
only her there are others but I think
all you can do is say over a period of
time is it changing and in my lifetime
it's certainly over the last footie I
mean if you get the football matches by
and large they are not Macy's chance any
longer there are not words if you went
30 years ago I mean it was really
unpleasant people food bananas or that's
the change now some of them are some of
those people who now know no longer
fokin are to still basis yeah let's not
care so I mean next point is right there
are still gonna be racist people but
it's changing with generations which is
great which is great but also the point
that I'm making here is that and I of
course unequivocally welcome to change
and my a life experience is completely
different to the experience of people
thirty years old of me who got chased
down the street by people with bats
trying to trying to hospitalize them
because they were black I've never
experienced that and thank God Megan
Markel is another in my view hugely
symbolic steps towards progress in our
society but the point that I'm making
Carol is elected in the media Jeremiah
is not the only person who thinks this
and furthermore it doesn't come from a
vacuum it comes from a long history
where overt racism turned into coded
racism and that is evident in the
initial press reports not just one years
ago thank you that's my point but I I
just so I'm telling you I don't see
color in people I don't regard someone
has been different if their skin tone is
one and another to me just people are
people and where I struggle a little bit
is I feel like I'm constantly having
stuff pushed onto me that makes me
consider racism in places that I never
even saw it so for example one of the
most recent things is that H&M
sweatshirt I saw this this little kid in
a sweatshirt cute little sweatshirt
forget about moved on this is the black
lad modeling a t-shirt the expression
cheeky little monkey know what you're
saying is well-meaning because do you
think as a white person in a society
where the majority people away you have
a good understand
of the ways in which race affects people
psychologically because when you say you
don't see racism Michelle I wouldn't
expect you to see it so if I'm quite
honest with you because it's not your
experience I wouldn't imagine you get
authored regularly I wouldn't imagine
that you carry and experience the
baggage of being in a country that
colonized on a white supremacist
ideology about the context you know it's
very easy to say that I have experience
that I've just written a book about
about the experience and not as an asset
how often have looks daily daily it's me
and this is the thing and I don't want
to get this not overt racism but acts of
other in Carol yes microaggressions
subtle prejudice that phone comes from
very well-meaning people who mean no one
if it's well-intentioned it's not racist
one of the problems I think is the idea
that I don't see race which is exactly
what you're saying which again Michelle
very well-intentioned I can see what
you're saying you are distancing
yourself from a history where people
judged each other based on race and were
prejudiced against people because of
their race right you're distancing
yourself and I anyone is different or
unequal I just see these doesn't mean to
say that other people don't because well
there are two things there are two
things one you are speak for when you
say you don't see something you are
blinding yourself to reality we live in
a world where racial injustice is the
structural part of our reality so if you
choose not to see it you are blind to
let me just finish secondly my heritage
is a black person is not something I
want you to be blind to it's part of who
I am so by saying you don't see it you
are blinding yourself to something I see
is positive and when people do that it
makes me question whether they still
think it's a negative thing but it's
better not to see my sentence is very
quick it's not that I when I say I don't
see it I don't feel towards you anything
although then what I feel towards you so
when I say I don't see it I'm not saying
it doesn't exist I'm saying I don't have
those thoughts anywhere in my body and a
huge number of other people do not
either